our enemies remain at home abroad and in
the skies beyond that world
[Music]
[Applause]
you look like the attractive cast of a
CW show Supergirl
season 2 premiere Monday October 10th on
the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie so Supergirl
trying to build some hype for season two
with a bunch of villains we'll also have
some talk about like a secret Wars like
universe combining event that they might
be doing in the future so here we go so
part of the fun of this is they just
want to show you that they're picking up
the pace now that they're bringing it to
the CW as if it felt a little bit slower
like it was on CBS like it was intended
for slightly older audiences now they're
not so worried about that CBS audience
so they can have a little more fun in
the very appropriate cat grant joke you
know you look like the attractive yet
non-threatening cast of a CW show just
winking at the CW itself because a lot
of their casts are like that you know
intended for young audiences so very
attractive yet non-threatening but
they're also trying to show you some of
the big things that are coming back and
season to some of these big villains
it's really a villains trailer so I
would expect upgraded versions of all
these like you have the CBS version then
you have the upgraded CW version even
the pace of the music lets you know that
things are going to be moving a lot
quicker even though the flash was always
on the CW I feel like it was the same
change between season 1 and season 2
like they picked up the pace they didn't
feel the need to kind of slow things up
so the people could follow along like
they're like okay people understand who
the flash is we don't need to over
explain things every single moment so in
keeping with that idea Supergirl just
gonna have a lot more fun with the
really weird cosmic things of the
Supergirl universe like if you don't
read the comics there's a Supergirl
rebirth title they tune things just a
little bit so that it's more in sync
with the TV show it doesn't follow the
TV show like the comics are always gonna
be separate from the TV shows but it's a
little closer to the tone of the TV show
she faces Kryptonian werewolves so just
a really crazy genre idea that's a lot
of fun so you can kind of see where I'm
headed with this The CW has a lot of fun
with genre shows Supergirl also going to
have a lot of fun with different genres
in Cadmus labs will kind of be like the
particle accelerator explosion you know
how like they created all those
metahumans on the flash they started
popping up things went crazy Cadmus labs
is where a lot of those types of stories
will surface on Supergirl
the people operating Cadmus will be the
big bads of the season and even though
they're not like really big comic-book
names that you might remember it is true
to the comics there were like really
evil people working inside Cadmus but
aside from cyborg superman and Cara's
father played by
kein being somewhere inside cabinets
like he's trapped in Cadmus we don't
know exactly what's gonna jump out of
there it's really just full of potential
they could do any number of different
things that they want but we actually do
know actually almost forgot metallo will
be like the first leadoff villain as
part of the Superman arc that tees up
the season we're almost within like the
four-week range of the premiere the
premiere is like the week after the
flash so once we get within that I think
they'll drop that Superman trailer we'll
see a little bit of metallo you'll get
an idea for how he's going to work on
the show that's another really big thing
too and I know you're all kind of hoping
that Dean Cain gets to be a version of
cyborg Superman that would be really
badass but it depends on how much
they're gonna change cyborg Superman
from the comics because technically it
should be Hank Henshaw which is who
Martian Manhunter has been emulating so
if you wanted to do it exactly like the
comics then the evil version of Hank
Henshaw the one that's still alive like
the true version he would come out as
cyborg superman
but i'm expecting a few twists they
haven't said much about him but I do
think that he'll be like one of the
biggest villains to come out of Cadmus
labs this season let me know in the
comments though which other villains do
you want them to bring on the show but
for now it seems like she's gonna stay
in a different universe so like her
earth won't be the same earth that Barry
and Oliver live on but they might change
that in the future I think they're just
taking their time like they don't want
to do everything all at once
flashpoints changing a lot of things but
it's not gonna be big enough to like
merge her earth with Barry's earth but
the big producer Greg Berlanti did
reference Secret Wars when he was
talking about the types of crossovers
that they try to do I mean he was
talking about Marvel and DC like crisis
on Infinite Earths Secret Wars so he was
really just making an offhanded
reference to the types of big crossovers
that happen in the comics but as you all
know during Marvel's Secret Wars they
did battle world where a bunch of
different earths got combined into one
earth so it's not out of the realm of
possibility that they will find a way to
merge Supergirl with Barry's earth but
let me know in the comments do you think
that they will ever do that or do you
think that Supergirl will always be in a
different universe it's totally possible
they could go either way with it but it
would be a lot of fun if they did like a
big crazy comic book story where they
combined her earth with Barry's it would
be one of the most comic-book things
they could possibly do aside from
bringing crypto onto the TV show not
really expecting Superdog but would be
really nice book ngratulations to this
week's giveaway winner matthew duck you
win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back into my
channel so I can get your contact
details there'll be some more DC and
Marvel later I might do some more
Justice League Deathstroke tonight just
talking about some of the actors the
biggest rumors that Joe Manganiello is
playing Deathstroke but I'll talk about
some of the different actors that could
pull it off there like a few really big
badass dudes that could do it and we got
some new Doctor Strange footage so I
actually I might do Doctor Strange first
tonight so should be along pretty
quickly well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn about
Jesse quick in season 3 of the flash you
can click here to watch that funny Thor
trailer again thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight